um yo so this is the fight that uh we're
we're getting obviously uh there's been
a lot of I mean everybody's asked you
about obviously whenever you're going to
fight Haney is this going to happen
after this fight is there any sort of
progression in those talks cuz I think
we keep hearing about the negotiations
falling through maybe he's not serious
about fighting you what it what is is is
that fight ever going to get made I
would love for the fight to happen um
[__] I y'all can clearly see that I want
the fight yeah like y'all can clearly
see I don't know why like people try to
spin the narratives and like a lot of
people good at social media so they'll
turn the narrative into something else
and 30 other people run with that
narrative but um truth be told I love to
fight like I I I fight anybody yeah um I
jumped in the ring with him for a reason
I didn't just jump in the ring and do
that for no other reason besides okay
let's get let's get the fight started
and and is the is what's off about it
still the split I think what's off about
it is his team like I don't think I
think his team is going to throw
anything out there to uh make sure the
fight don't happen um I don't think that
they want the fight to happen right now
um that's what I heard like from what I
was hearing I'm I'm hearing that well
that's what it feels like there's so
many weird politics and box
that I don't think people understand if
you're just like a generic boxing fan
cuz you're like well this should be easy
like this guy and this guy they want to
fight this is a big money fight there's
a lot of money to be made but sometimes
like you said there's timing yeah it's
business and that's business above
everything and that's how they looking
at it they see it as okay why we fight
this big RIS fighter right now rather
than wait a couple of years where we we
could make more money but yeah they
could run it cuz if they lose to you
that's going to [__] up that that might
[__] up his bag yeah and like like like
you know it's it's almost like what
happened with um for people who are like
casual boxing fans it's like Jake Paul
losing Y is bad for business yes right
so he has to keep winning so the fact
that he lost to Tyson or Tommy Fury is
is is uh was was kind of bad for
business yeah but like I say him and
that one dude well his his brother and
that one dude uh they they stirred up
some [__] but and that fight was
terrible my only issue with it right if
that's the case don't
perpetrate as if you're that's what you
want to do you know you're perpetrating
and acting like that um this is what you
want and um you talking big but truth be
told um you put me and him in a in a
ring where nobody else can help him
there's nobody else that going to be
able to fight for him what's going to
happen like he know deep down
inside that I'm the truth that's what he
know he know he done been in the ring
with me several times um he go ask him
like really ask him and tell him to be
honest about me as a fighter um you
really hear how he talk and um honestly
I think he's a good fighter but um I
think that is levels um I just saw uh J
Prince was uh out in Saudi Arabia with
Vince McMahon and Kanye at the fight
what's your relationship these days like
with J Prince oh that's my guy that's my
guy uh like I said um in other
interviews I appreciate him I appreciate
everything that he done for me um
he's he he's family to me so um I I got
nothing but good things to say about Jay
uh I appreciate him yeah when you go to
Houston are you just like do you get the
red carpet yeah for sure you go to htown
yeah have you been to Onyx out there onx
uh good place I don't know establishment
I don't remember if I've been there or
not I was just there a few days ago we
uh we went hog hunting hog hunting yeah
but this rapper there's a rapper out
there named Mexican OT and he took his
hog hunting and in a helicopter we were
like hanging out the side of a in a
helicopter bro I swear to God we were
hanging out the side of a helicopter
with AR-15 shooting
pigs by the way they're Pest and they're
invasive species so in my mind I felt
like I was you know helping helping
Farmers out you know what I'm saying n i
I've done it before but you've done that
not in no helicopter but you killed the
pigs no I shot at him I ain't I a i a
hit nothing n a but you did it in Texas
yeah oh so you did you did what did you
have the night vision goggles yeah oh
yeah so yeah we did that too yeah yeah
for sure you sure you didn't hit nothing
n I'm sure I ain't hit nothing bro you
had the goggles you got the scope I'm
sure I didn't hit that you missed on
purpose you're a good man nah it was
like a uh they was further down I smoked
them they wasn't uh as close yeah no it
was fun it was like I felt like I was in
like with the night goggles at cuz we
did the helicopter and then we did the
nighttime [__] I felt like I was in Call
of Duty and then they were near some
cows and they were like you know they
could kill those cows I was like not
yeah cuz I'mma kill them first they save
some Cattle Man this dude crazy um yo um
yeah talk obviously you're real tight
with bud with Terence Crawford
um how you feeling about a rematch
between him and uh
Spence uh my honest opinion on it um I
think that Errol is a great fighter I
think that um he's tough and and he got
the Heart of a Lion for even wanted to
do a rematch with butd but um my honest
opinion I don't want to see it like I
wouldn't want to watch the first fight
was so like definitive yeah that it was
like it be you know it wasn't like it
was just too one-sided exactly yeah like
if it was more so like a competitive
fight then it'll be like okay ID like to
see it but it wasn't like competitive
enough for me to like want to watch it
again but that's just my opinion on I
don't want nobody take it the wrong way
but um I don't want to see it so you're
fight fighting Edwin de los Santos yes
um I don't know who the hell this guy is
so I'm assuming that you're going to
beat the living [__] out of this guy
yeah n but he's he's a good fighter I'm
going to put it out there and say U I
watched him uh he got good boxing skills
um you got to respect your opponent at
all times man no no he's a good fighter
though no I'm saying but you have to
like I feel like sometimes we see our
like boxers popping [__] in press
conferences and I'm like yo man like
this guy's still professional there's a
reason why he's fighting you so this
guy's good what I'm saying is you just
got to be aware of who you're in the
ring with sometimes and being aware of
that you don't want to sleep on nobody
and uh sleeping on that dude would be
like the wrong move for me to make so um
this dude is a great boxer puncher and
um you could tell that he's hungry and
he's going to come to win so uh for sure
I I respect him as a a fighter but he's
just going against the best he's going
against the best and I'm sure all the
money in Vegas is on you so yeah for
sure yeah I always wonder cuz you know I
used to live in Vegas and betting on
fights was so much fun do you ever like
think to yourself like if I lose people
are eating [__] at the sports book hell
no n I ain't thinking like that um I'm
tip fighter I be so confident that I'll
go bet on myself oh that is that allowed
uh I mean if you do it the right way
yeah Floyd used to do that yeah I don't
I don't know I think I don't know uh can
you go to the casinos and do it but I
can one time I interviewed 50 Cent when
I was living in Vegas and Floyd was
fighting that weekend and 50 had a
million dollars in a backpack he brought
it to the radio station he's like I'm
about to take this across the street put
on Floyd I said damn he's like for Floyd
but I I I did that and I lost before cuz
I had bet on the um
knockout you lost money on yourself man
I lost like uh I want to say 15,000 on
myself so you bet you were going to
knock them out yes cuz it was it was a
fight that they didn't think I was going
to knock come out which fight was this
it was um against Robson CU say sou and
that's why the whole fight like my
coaches like they telling me like chill
chill chill I'm like the whole fight in
your head you're like I got to win this
money I'm about to knock this
[__] out that's all I was
thinking of like I'm trying to get the
knockout but they telling me like yo
just box your way into it I'm like no
forget what y'all talking about lay him
out I'm going to get him like we're
about to take yeah what you know what
the what the payout would have been cuz
I'm sure the odds had to be positive uh
I don't remember what the payout was but
I know I bet like 15 bands on me
stopping that dude before like the ninth
round that's so fire and I was so mad
that I didn't yo I love that dude um in
your opinion man um removing yourself
from the equation who you think right
now is the best pound-for-pound fighter
best pound-for-pound fighter yeah
Terence Crawford it ain't even no no
question about it it ain't nothing to
think about um teran's been dominating
the sport for years uh Canelo is a great
fighter but we didn't seen him lose on
several occasions and um we still
haven't seen nobody crack the cold on
how to beat Terence Crawford so um
something in that Nebraska water you
know what I'm saying